Greetings everybody, my name is Sam Deiter and I'm a senior Unreal Engine instructor with Epic Games.
In the following video tutorial series, I'm going to introduce you to the various tools and feature Unreal Engine 5 provides
and give you a brief explanation of what they do so you can make a better choice on whether or not you want to utilize these tools and features
and whatever project you happen to be creating.
Now there is a lot to cover so we are first going to start by taking a look at the Unreal Engine 5 documentation.
This is a great place to start learning more about all of the tools and features Unreal Engine 5 supports as well as get more detailed explanations
should you be having trouble with a particular tool or feature or you want to learn more about how a particular tool or feature works.
Next we are going to take a look at the Epic Games Launcher. This tool is used to not only download and manage various versions of the Unreal Engine 5 editor
it can also be utilized to help you manage any projects that you happen to create or download as well as content that you might have purchased or downloaded from the FAB marketplace.
Then we are going to take a look at the Unreal Engine project structure as understanding how projects are structured is key to ensuring smooth delivery of your project to either teammates
or when you happen to cook your project for consoles, PC or mobile devices.
Then we are going to take a look at the content pipeline so that you can understand how easy it is to get content from various digital content creation programs into Unreal Engine 5 to use inside of your projects.
We are then going to take a look at the editor UI so we can familiarize ourselves with the various areas and interactions that we will need to build upon in order to be most successful when we use the engine.
Then we are going to take a look at actors as all of our Unreal Engine 5 projects are going to utilize actors in some way, shape or form.
Finally, we are going to finish up by taking a look at some of the most common tools and features Unreal Engine 5 provides and go over any interesting information you might need to be aware of in order to get the best utilization from these tools.
We have a lot to cover so let's go ahead and get started with the Unreal Engine 5 documentation.